this episode of the minimalists is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
non-minimalists
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live
a meaningful life with less my name is
joshua fields milburn and i'm ryan
nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists dude how nice is it
that it's just been you and i the last
few episodes i really enjoyed it i like
having guests we'll get back to having
some guests
really soon but i enjoy having these
conversations especially with the
direction
some of these conversations have been
taking
it's not just minimalism although that's
certainly a component of all of these
discussions these conversations these
podcast episodes we're having it's
intentional living it's simple living
but it's about understanding and getting
a deeper understanding and today
we want to invite you to unsubscribe
and unfollow yeah anything
that doesn't bring tranquility or
increase your well-being
now ryan we just had this essay that hit
our website i thought i'd read
a bit from this essay it is called the
great unsubscribe
i love it you and i can have a
conversation about this it starts like
this
a decade ago shortly after starting our
website we published an essay that
invited our audience to unfollow
the minimalists why because we want to
add value to your life
not digital clutter to your screens and
it's also because we're minimalists
yes we wanted to minimize
our audience as much as possible the
funny thing is we had a really tiny
audience back then
right and so we're kind of doing it
again the essay goes on to say
so please unsubscribe if our work no
longer
serves you naturally this philosophy
extends beyond
the minimalists clinging to media that
disrupts one's tranquility
be it a tv show magazine newsletter
or influencer account is a vacuous
endeavor
that was in quotes influencer yes yeah
over the past 10 years the minimalists
have continued to ask people to walk
away from our blog
podcasts and social media if it stops
advancing their well-being
but we're taking it one step further
this month
this is a little this makes me a little
nervous i generally don't get nervous to
do this but that nervousness is an
attachment it's exposing an attachment
of mine
so i thought maybe we could talk about
this ryan but the essay goes on to say
today we are removing more than a
hundred
thousand people from our email
newsletter
and you're not it's not you opting out
it's us opting you
out uh so anyone who has not
opened one of our emails in the last
month
30 days yeah man that is um
that's a pretty strict boundary right
but we are all about boundaries
yes um what if uh
uh i guess there's a bunch of what ifs
isn't there 30 days sounds good
i love that there is a bunch of what-ifs
isn't there yeah yeah and so
yeah uh jeff who is our developer he and
i were looking at this and sort of just
identify
and we're actually going to start with a
little bit wider net and close into this
30-day
area in which we're and it's more than
100 000 people but it just tells me like
if you haven't opened up an email
of ours in the last month there's
nothing wrong with that
but hey why are you and i paying to to
send emails to that person in the first
place but then also
forget that why am i cluttering their
inbox
i'm doing the opposite of what you and i
set out to do
right it's certainly not adding value if
you're not opening anything now
at that point it's kind of like
unintentional spam yes
now if we accidentally unsubscribed you
can always re-subscribe
yeah or if you even unsubscribe yourself
you can re-subscribe in the future if
you decide hey you know what
i i miss that thing it was adding value
to my life etc
nothing is final in the blog life hey i
thought i'd butt in real quick and
talk about this add some clarity there
are some folks we may have
accidentally unsubscribed you and you
didn't want us to unsubscribe you from
the list now
you'll know if that is you because you
received an email
that lets you know you've been
unsubscribed if that was done by a
mistake if you are indeed
finding value from our emails simply
head on over to the
minimalists.com and re-subscribe we
won't unsubscribe you again
and i think it's worth noting that we're
not
using your data or your email for
anything we certainly wouldn't give your
information or
god forbid sell your information to
anyone
what we did is we just checked to see
whether or not you've opened an email
of ours recently now some people might
have some sort of filter that
doesn't tell us whether or not you did
so we may have inadvertently removed you
from the email list but if we did
you received an email about that as well
if you'd like to resubscribe you can
certainly do so but please do so
if and only if you find value in what
we're creating and what we're
podcasting about and what we're writing
about it's 100 free to be on that email
list but
we do not want to clutter your inbox so
if you'd like re-subscribe at
theminimalists.com
and enjoy a little bit more of less
if there's a simple way to carry this
out on social media or our podcast
we would do it there too this great
unsubscribe will free up space to
produce meaningful creations for the
people who desire to explore the benefit
of living with less without yearning for
the approval
of the uninterested masses you see
while it might seem impressive to have
millions of readers listeners
followers and subscribers it was never
about the numbers by the way that's the
the one line that stands out most that's
the the key
takeaway from this whole thing is it was
never about
the numbers it has always been about
creating and understanding
creating something genuine understanding
the truth everything else is excess
so feel free to unfollow the minimalists
or stick around if you benefit from our
words but
if we cease adding value please remember
peace is just an unfollow away
that's a great last line why thank you
so
i think that the thing that i want to
illustrate here and on the maximal
episode this week ryan we are going to
talk about peace and tranquility and
what exactly that means in fact we'll
even be
discussing that a bit here on this
minimal episode but i had some follow-up
from last week ryan we did
a maximal episode on the private podcast
about the broken news
oh yeah last week oh man i've actually
stopped looking at the news
a couple days ago it wasn't the day
after we did that podcast but
oh man it's unbelievable how much more
peaceful
life is without the news without the
misery in a way
and not the bad news yeah yeah i mean uh
without all the conflict introducing
unnecessary conflict into our life
in fact during the lightning round today
ryan i do want to talk to you
about conflict for those of you who need
to catch up you can go back and listen
to that two-hour conversation ryan
interviewed me on our private podcast we
did about an
hour on the news and the media and sort
of how
we're unfollowing certain things and
then we did another hour on hidden
clutter and let our audience weigh in on
some some clutter stuff
well you know it's it was after the
insurrection
that i got like really stuck on the bad
news
and i just remember thinking like man
josh
is i bet he's so tranquil right now like
not looking at the news
and uh yeah so i wanted to have a
conversation with you
about not looking at the news but then i
was like oh we should save that for the
podcast because i know i'm not the only
one
who was like struggling with that so it
was a great conversation i'm glad we did
it
and hopefully uh you know people were
able to
have a different perspective on on the
media that they take in
one thing i can tell you is i did leave
a few things out because we were talking
about some of the things i answered i
in fact gave a list of all the things
that i unsubscribed from in terms of the
news
but there are other things that are sort
of news adjacent that i also
unsubscribed from so really this episode
we're calling it the unfollowing
i unfollowed a bunch of people on social
media
it was nothing against them personally
but they were
not aiding my tranquility in fact they
were
they were getting in the way they were
sharing certain things that
interfered with my tranquility i didn't
take it personally
[Laughter]
i'd never unfollow you ryan what did we
say
last week about you know it's hard to
look at someone and say
i'd rather be happy than have you in my
life but maybe even to take it a step
further
what you were you know well that's
basically basically what you were saying
but to take a step further you can look
at someone else and be like i'd rather
you be happy than me in your life yes
and that's really how i feel about you
like if you did unfollow me
i would feel like you know what i'd
rather you be unhappy than have me in
your life
well that's a or i'd rather you be happy
than have me in your life and that's a
mature
way to look at it because what you're
doing is you're stepping back and not
allowing the sort of emotion it's easy
for us to
by the way this is all emotion based
right all of these conversations that
we're having here
involve some sort of emotional tug
toward i'm supposed to
follow this news i am supposed to be an
informed
citizen i'm supposed to
listen to good media and weed out the
bad
media these are all judgments that we
don't need to thrust upon things
all i need to do is say hey there are
certain twitter feeds and
social media feeds and podcasts and
newsletters
that are not that are interfering with
my tranquility
and so there i went through all of my
podcasts and unsubscribed very quickly
unsubscribe unsubscribe unsubscribe i
did the same
with a bunch of email newsletters i
don't know about you but sometimes it
feels like every time i open my email
i'm spending half of my time just
unsubscribing from things
that i didn't even know i signed up for
yeah there are two newsletters i'm
signed up for
and i won't even tell you which two
because i don't want to make anyone feel
like they should go sign up for it's not
a recommendation right
right yeah so what i've realized
throughout this whole process ryan is
everybody is suffering
we already know that but media
is only increasing the suffering i
didn't say the
media i mean media in the sense that
like
all of these vehicles through which
information is delivered to us
is increasing our misery increasing our
suffering and why is that is because
we're constantly
chasing ephemeral bits of pleasure
and through that we're running away from
misery but yeah misery is much faster
than we can ever run
you know even like another perspective
on it
uh i went to i went to the news for
answers like i'd get anxious and we
talked about this on that podcast but
it's like you go there for the ephemeral
bits of happiness uh
for whatever it is but for me it was
like i thought that the news was going
to give me an
answer that i was seeking and it
never does that right i can't think of
once where i've been went to the news
i'm like oh
that's the answer i was looking for
right because we're actually not looking
for
answers we're looking for confirmation
yeah
and yeah and so answer
is is a dangerous thing because
we don't actually want help the person
who wants help will find the help that
they want right
even the person who who thinks that
they're seeking
help is often seeking confirmation
yeah can you please give me permission
to do the thing i already knew was
i was i was going to do in the first
place and i want to feel better about
the decision i've already
made we have a question here from
jackson in johnson city tennessee
i have begun starting the act of being a
minimalist
and today my partner facetimed me and i
told her what i was getting rid of
and we had the biggest fight and then
she diagnosed me
she diagnosed me and wrote a bunch of
quotes saying i need to get help
but this could be bigger than just being
a minimalist this could actually be a
personality
issue that is supplementing that
i just thought i was torn between two
worlds one person trying to diagnose me
and then one heavy influence that i've
been getting um from the podcast for
months
i just want to see you guys think
personality disorder
minimalism is there anything that is
connected
so i hear this word disorder right the
world
is disorder and and it's not the natural
state by the way
but the world for the last 12 000 years
has been approaching increasing levels
of disorder ever since we sort of
form civilizations we have
relied on other people's perspective for
order right and so
i would say that yeah we all have
personality disorders
and if you're asking me to diagnose you
with something
i obviously can't do that i'm not
qualified to do that but i will say
i'll diagnose everyone with a
personality disorder of some sort
meaning we
whenever we approach something we are
doing so from a perspective of society
of culture
and culture always leads to chaos
and so it's the new stuff we were
talking about last week
or it is the newsletters that are
showing up in your inbox or it's the
people
who are tweeting at you or it's whatever
we are seeking out there's gonna be
bits of chaos just interwoven throughout
society
yeah the disorder is already
there and minimalism jackson
is a way for us to
find some order in our lives i say find
because it's really uncovering the order
the order that exists it's the order of
of nature it's the natural order we even
hear that phrase right
anything that disrupts nature then is
disorder and so we we use these terms
disease
chaos it's all the it's all the same
fabric though and so minimalism is not a
way for
it's not a destination that we're going
to it's a tool that we use
to clear that clutter
to make the order you can't organize
your way
to order right you can have a really
cluttered house that is
organized but that's not order
it's simply orderly i like how you said
find some order because
you know just reiterating what you said
about minimalism not being a destination
so it's not about well if you're having
any
troubles in your life any disorder
become a minimalist and you're going to
find all the order
right it just helps you filter through a
lot of the noise
i really wish jackson would have told us
what he was getting rid of
that caused this argument because if it
was like
an antique vas you know i mean that's
his girlfriend's projecting yeah if it's
his head
well that's a problem right he might
have a disorder if he wants to minimize
his head
so obviously he doesn't want to minimize
his head but it is interesting how
when we start to find some order
especially through something like
minimalism because it's such a
what's the word i'm looking for like it
is i'm looking for an adjective
it is a very like um disruptive word
yeah
and it's a disruptive lifestyle because
it's disrupting the chaos
right and whenever we do that in our
lives
especially uh you know we'll hear this
from people who
are experiencing a lot of disorder
themselves they start to
project judgment and you know really his
girlfriend is what she's saying she's
not saying jackson you have a disorder
what she's saying is
is if i was in your shoes and if i
started to think about getting rid of
whatever it is that he was thinking
about getting rid of
there would be something wrong with me
therefore there must be something wrong
with you
and it's very difficult especially when
it's our partner
um to uh to not take that personally and
to not actually have this question like
is there something wrong with me i mean
i remember and you know when we were
working
in our corporate jobs and people were
asking me if you were thinking about
killing yourself
because i was getting rid of stuff it
was the same thing yeah what disorder
does he have
right and i'm like yeah josh has been
thinking about killing himself for years
i don't think he's actually going to do
it though
this is how i can prevent me from
killing myself right
yeah what's fascinating about that is i
the projection thing is spot on ryan and
especially that right or wrong thing
what what she may be doing again
you're right it does depend on what
those items are because if you got rid
of all of her stuff
that's a problem that is a problem i'm
becoming a minimalist and i decided i'm
getting rid of all your things
hey honey we're minimalists now where's
my stuff
actually you're a minimalist
[Laughter]
so uh yeah we want to be careful with
that
making sure that it is is my stuff
that i am getting rid of i'm not
thrusting this upon someone else
and at the same time it's it's important
to realize that when she's projecting
that onto you she
is also creating a moralizing stance of
right or wrong
and my way of living is right or correct
and your way of your new way of living
is
is wrong or right and i'll say this
hope you don't get upset about it but no
hope involved here really
jackson your path is not the right path
either the path of minimalism is not the
right
path right and her path is not
the wrong path and vice versa
the question is what is appropriate and
what what are the outcomes that you're
seeing what are you seeking
right are you seeking peace are you
seeking tranquility
then well removing some of that chaos
will get us closer to that we're
uncovering the piece
as opposed to finding it chasing you
can't chase
peace it doesn't work that way and so
yeah when i look at getting rid of stuff
that's the that's the initial bite at
the
apple but it also means that you're
going to start looking inward and
simplifying
the relational clutter the career
clutter
the existential angst clutter
all of these these additional clutters
that go way beyond the stuff they
manifest
in those material possessions and
that can all cause i think it can cause
initially
some additional chaos up front because
when you're when you start to see this
kind of truth for what it is
you realize like oh
the last 30 years i've been living
a lie and it wasn't a lie in the sense
that like i was intentionally
doing something quote unquote wrong it
was a lie in the sense that i didn't
know
the truth and it it only continues to be
a lie if i continue to go down that path
knowing that it is inappropriate for me
yeah you know one thing i'll throw out
here too for jackson
is when you have a
romantic partner in your life um
your decisions affect that person
so i know with mariah and i
she might say something or have an idea
to do something like i'm thinking about
she had brought up i forget what it was
but you know there are things that
like as soon as she brings it up i'm i
have this like visceral feeling of like
well that's not practical that doesn't
make any sense and like i automatically
push against her
yes um and as soon as i catch myself
actually creating a problem when there
wasn't a problem
i will take a step back and i will start
to try and work with her
and try and meet in the middle somewhere
so
uh i'm not saying that you know jackson
has to do what his partner says
but when you have even a business
partner with you and i mean we have to
consider each other's perspectives and
um uh you know our um
tastes and there's another word i'm
looking for they can't think of right
now but
yeah preferences exactly so that is it's
it's important
if you want your girl to respect your
preferences you're gonna have to respect
her preferences and sometimes that takes
a really difficult conversation
um but i'm just throwing that out there
for jackson to you know hopefully help
him avoid
uh these arguments in the future jackson
i'd love to send you a copy of our new
book and i say new it's not even out yet
but it's called love people use things
sean if you put him on the list there's
an entire chapter in there about our
relationship with people it's a
relationship book
goes beyond the stuff in fact it starts
with our relationship with the stuff but
it's about the seven
essential relationships in our life one
of those
relationships with our stuff one of them
is with the truth one of them's with
ourself
so forth and so on the very last chapter
in the book is about our relationship
with people i think you'll find value in
love people use things if you want to
pre-order it
it helps us out a lot love people use
things.net
as the place that you can pre-order it
ryan what time is it you know what time
it is it is time for the lightning round
where we answer
your text messages you can text your
questions and comments to
four 937-202-4600 five four yes indeed
those texts go to both of our phones
now during the lightning round this is
where ryan and i do our best to answer
every question with a short shareable
less than 140 character response
we put the text to these minimal maxims
in the show notes so you can copy and
share our pithy answers
on social media if you'd like and oh by
the way you can find all of our minimal
maxims in one place now
minimalmaxims.com marianne has a
question for us
we can't impose tranquility on the world
around us
so how do we adjust our internal
settings
to maintain inner tranquility i i
the reason i like this question is
because
it's very honest and it exposes the
truth here about
tranquility so here is i'm going to give
you a pithy answer i actually have three
pithy answers for you here
but my first one is imposed peace always
leads to
conflict and that's the thing that we
often try to do especially in a
relationship with
others is i'm going to force you to be
peaceful
yeah i'm going to force anything on onto
you persuade you coerce you
that does not work in fact it
accomplishes the opposite right
yeah if i'm tie you down and say be
peaceful
that's like me telling you to be in the
moment yeah
it sounds good i guess
maybe but living in the moment isn't
good or bad anyway it simply
is and we either are living in the
moment or we are
living for the future or the past which
is where most of us spend our
time living and so
you're talking about imposing
tranquility yes an imposed piece
always leads to conflict so how do we
adjust our internal settings to maintain
inner tranquility well i will say this
here's my other
pithy answer for you all conflict arises
from
within there is no such thing as
external conflict
it may feel that way someone does
something
to you but they do something to you only
in so far as you allow that thing to be
done to you the insult or whatever in
fact i wanted to read a
an excerpt from direct truth it's a
kapil gupta's book
and i thought this was a perfect answer
to this question for marianne
and it this chapter is titled
why do i get angry when i am insulted
hmm do you get angry when you're
insulted someone says something snide to
you on social media
sometimes something gets different i get
defensive more than insulted yeah
yeah and so well maybe not externally
defensive but i start to feel
defensive so when someone insults you do
you get defensive
and you would say yes to that right yeah
i don't know if i like voice my
defensiveness i try not to
but the visceral feeling is definitely
like a defense it's an internal feeling
too right
it doesn't exist in the real world it's
simply something that has
arisen within you right yeah so this is
this chapter
in this book in fact this entire book
which i read in a single sitting and
then re-read it the next day
a phenomenal book we'll put a link to it
in the show notes called direct truth
by kapil gupta and the
it's written as a q a right so it's
question
answer question answer right it's a it's
like a student and a master
sort of having a conversation together
right and so i'll start with the
question and then i'll use a slightly
different voice for the answer
why do i get angry when i'm insulted
because you entertain the rarity of the
insult
how so how not so if someone calls me
stupid it does not mean that i'm stupid
nor does it mean that you are not but
i don't believe myself to be stupid then
anger would not arise within you
anger arises within me because they
unjustly accuse me of being stupid
i see you don't agree i understand that
you would like me to agree
um i would like to know
i've already answered you but my answer
was not to your liking
but i i don't think of myself as stupid
i understand you don't believe me
i do not need your assistance in seeing
the truth
do you believe me that i think do you
believe that i think i am stupid
this question does not interest me
then how are you able to answer my
question
i have already answered it there's a
parenthesis here
this woman walked away in anger then
returned two weeks later
oh this is a legit conversation one of
his uh clients oh well yeah
would you like me to tell you why i've
returned
if you wish i realized something
i was getting angry about you not
believing me when i said i didn't think
i was stupid
the fact that this made me angry
ironically illustrated the very point
that you were trying to make am i
correct am i correct
yes i apologize for my foolishness
i am now ready to hear your answer
[Music]
[Laughter]
i have already given you my answer which
is to say that
if i become angry at being called stupid
i believe myself to be stupid
i wonder if you might expand upon this
for me
if someone calls you a bird would you
become angry
no why not because
being called a bird is not an insult
very well
if someone were to call you a bird that
was too stupid to flap its wings
would this make you angry no
why not because it isn't true at all
yet when you were called stupid it makes
you angry
because something within you entertains
the possibility
that you might in fact be stupid
then something else within you grows
irritated by the idea
that you might be this internal conflict
manifests itself
as anger i see so
if not a single iota of a belief about
being stupid existed within me
that anger would not arise that is
correct
hmm that's good man
there's like it's funny because the and
i don't
know if that's in what you just read but
there is
the truth that when someone calls you
stupid
and you start to get to and i start to
get defensive i'll put it on me someone
calls me stupid
i start to get defensive it's for for me
it's one or two reasons it's
either a piece of me thinks that maybe i
am stupid
um and then for some reason there's
another piece of me
that feels misunderstood yes
in that i'm doing something to make
people
think that i'm stupid right which is
which are both
in the ego but it's interesting how
sometimes the defense mechanism comes up
out of fear
of people believing something that isn't
true
right it's the the bird analogy there
right right like why do people think i'm
a bird
yeah if they're not a bird said ryan and
i would insult you too by saying
your feathers are the ugliest color hmm
you would just dismiss that right and
yet
and i misunderstand you mm-hmm i
clearly misunderstand you i mean it's a
fundamental misunderstanding of who
and what you are yeah but you're not
insulted by that at all
no although maybe like i take it to a
metaphorical sense what does he mean by
feathers
but yeah no i i understand what you're
saying yeah yeah here's here's one more
pithy answer for you we put this in the
show notes if one has a deep enough
desire to eliminate conflict they will
remove anything that produces
that conflict that was really the start
of this conversation ryan
even last week when we were talking
about the news and removing things it's
not about what you should do
i don't have a prescription in terms of
well here are the things that you
should subscribe to and not subscribe to
it is simply that if there's something
that is creating
conflict then
and you have a sincere desire a deep
desire
to eliminate conflict it's not to say
you should have a desire to
by the way most people don't have that
desire at all in fact the opposite is
true have you been in a relationship
before ryan
where bickering was sort of the the
order of the day
yeah where it's how it was the the way
that in which
you communicated with each other me too
and and i i realized that in parenting
that was something that i was doing as
well i was bickering with my daughter
as a po and i was creating unnecessary
conflict in her and in me
right also kapil would say all conflict
is self-conflict
i just sort of reworked that to say it
rises from within
but but when i look at at that type of
conflict
that i'm creating i also realize that if
i don't want that conflict
then i should certainly re then it makes
sense for me to remove
anything that is producing the conflict
right that's minimalism right it started
with the stuff
it was creating this terrible conflict
in my life
but understanding that led to the action
it wasn't the other way around it wasn't
the
oh i picked up a book on decluttering
and i learned these seven steps and now
i've removed the conflict from my life
no
it was about understanding that conflict
then
all the action sort of happens on its
own after that
yeah you can get some tips or whatever
that help with the sort of mechanics of
decluttering that's not a problem at all
sure
but the decluttering alone will not
bring you tranquility
tweet that podcast sean that's right um
i picked the answer i actually got
i just thought of another one my first
one is tranquility is not a destination
so important to recognize that and what
i mean by that is
it's the same thing with minimalism it's
the same thing with happiness
i mean these are tranquility i believe
is ephemeral
and as you were talking i was kind of in
my own little thought of like why is
tranquility ephemeral like is it
possible
to live in this state of nirvana
and it is but like when i think of
people who have reached that state
they really don't spend a lot of time
around other people no
and by the way they can't that's a whole
different conversation
right but but one of the greatest
uh lies that we've we've been told is
that like our happiness or joy is going
to come from other people
no what's the saying other people are
hell
like there's something to that yeah but
it made me think about like
uh yeah other people are made me think
of like uh you ever heard of the term
bodhi sativa
where it's like um basically it's
someone who has discovered how to reach
nirvana
but they postpone it out of the you know
the valiant
uh feeling of wanting to help others
to reach nirvana themselves so it's
i'm not sure how much you know i'm like
it bought into that
term but um i do understand that like to
really
reach a constant state of tranquility
you can't be around a lot of other
people so tranquility is not a
destination and then the other thing i
thought of
you know buddha talks about how uh life
is suffering
um you could i could depend that and say
life is conflict
and it is life is conflict right and in
all conflict
as kapil says is self-conflict right
and so once we recognize that for what
it is
that all these conflicts are arising
within me
yeah it's not the news that made me
miserable
yeah right it is simply a trigger for
misery to arise
and so by removing those things that are
they're triggering the misery
all of a sudden i i have less conflict
as a consequence
yeah all right ryan before we get to our
listener comments and our added value
segment today it looks like we got a
bunch more surprise
questions this week like how can i
balance tranquility
and kids what advice would you give to
someone who is a
tech enthusiast and wants to be a
minimalist
that's a that's a roundabout way that is
a tranquility question right
yeah because tech often disrupts our
peace
how do you go about reducing stress and
promoting tranquility
with work life plus a million more
questions about peace and tranquility
for
the minimalist and if you want to hear
all that listen to the minimalist
private podcast this week
visit the minimalists.com support to
subscribe and get your personal link
so that our private podcast plays in
your favorite podcast app
if you enjoy our show and want to
support the minimalists this is the only
way our
podcast earns money so come on it's
cheaper than a cup of coffee
and it keeps our show 100 advertisement
free plus
private podcast subscribers also gain
access to hundreds of hours
of archives ryan what you got for us
this week here are some voicemail
comments and insights from our listeners
check them out hi
this is brooke from new brighton i was
calling in response to episode 133
constraints
i'm responding to derek's question about
wanting to travel more
but feeling constrained since he shares
custody of his daughter
josh had mentioned on the podcast how he
found a school that was more flexible
with ella's absences
my suggestion for derek is to look into
cyber charter schools
there are many cyber schools for
kindergarten through 12th grade now
that are either with any state or with
or a few that are country-wide
i think that is something worth looking
into and might provide him the
flexibility
or opportunity to travel or even take
his daughter with him in that case
i actually work for a cyber school in
pennsylvania and love it
i think it is a great option and it
provides me with flexibility i never
thought was possible
with a profession in teaching but i also
see
the view as a teacher and how it
provides a lot of flexibility
for students and they have opportunity
to travel and
do other things that otherwise wouldn't
be possible
hello minimalist my name is malia and i
live in victorville which is a small
city in california
i just wanted to help everyone out there
and let them know that if you
hate daily planners and you feel like
it's a clutter bug
and you don't like it and it's too
restrictive for you
i would like to suggest a bullet journal
you can look it up on pinterest or
online
i find that pinterest keeps me the most
creative but it helps you plan out your
day
and use blank pages to your
best interest and so i can write
whatever i want on any page and still
plan out my week
my meals my grocery list and it puts
everything that i want all of the lists
all of the little notes all of you know
the sticky notes that i would keep
around my house it keeps them all in one
place
and having one book for everything
because it's a blank page book and you
get to write it in
not only keeps me creative but keeps me
organized so for everyone out there
who's trying to be more intentional
but you take a lot of notes use a bullet
journal
all right y'all for our added value
segment this week let's listen to a song
at the end of this episode
it's called busy and it's by the band we
which is spelled v-v-e
this is from the soundtrack to our film
les
is now man they nailed it they nailed
the whole soundtrack such a good job
yeah yeah
it's not our soundtrack we simply
license it from them now ryan the band
is called
we although so nate and drew were the
two guys who formed the band just for us
they
did the music for our first film
minimalism and now they've done the the
music for
this newest film on netflix and they put
out a music video
for the song busy it's so
so good you've got to check it out
because it really illustrates how absurd
busyness is oh dude i can't wait to see
they've perfectly illustrated now the
band
itself the name is we spelled vve
except i just recognized that drew
calls it we and nate calls it v-v-e
oh really and so the two guys in the
band
say it differently and people often ask
me is it pronounced vve or we
and i guess the answer to that is
whatever you want i'm going to start
calling it v
v drawing out the v
wrong you're like it could be any way
you want except that way
[Laughter]
no i i so uh yeah i i call it we because
i think drew is the one who actually
came up with the name
so he just wanted a creative way because
it is about
a we right this collective that came
together to make
we made this music basically was
was the sort of idea behind it anyway
the song
is called busy and it per the song
itself which you're here in a moment
perfectly illustrates
the absurdity of how we just
fill our days with we inundate our days
with
nonsense and you really see it in the
music video
and it made me just recognize how often
do i do
that how often do i do with that even
now when i'm
supposedly living intentionally these
are all the things that are what
disrupting my tranquility and so
perhaps since we're talking about
unfollowing i need to unfollow
it would make sense for me if if if con
reducing conflict is the objective here
then it makes sense for me to unfollow
some of these practices of of my past
real quick for right here right now
here's one thing that's going on in the
life
of the minimalist we have a lot of new
listeners right now did you know that
you can
tour our homes the minimalists.com
resources you can find a bunch of free
resources there including two video
tours
for ryan's home my home
you can see who's more minimalist you'll
never guess what my
favorite item is click here to find out
if you're interested in seeing the sort
of visuals behind our homes
the minimalists.com resources you can
find a bunch of other free
resources there as well you can follow
the minimalists on
facebook twitter and instagram at the
minimalist that's also where you can
unfollow the minimalists
come see one of our live podcast shows
visit the minimalists.com
tour to find a city near you if you have
a question comment or minimalism tip for
our podcast email a voice memo
to podcast at theminimalists.com you can
comment on this episode youtube.com
slash the minimalists and if you want
our show notes in your inbox
sign up for our email list over at the
minimalists.com
unsubscribe anytime you'd like you'll
also receive our simple sunday emails
we send those out just writings about
minimalism and intentional living
and if you leave here today with one
message let it be this
love people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all we'll see you next
time
[Music]
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'd be fine
without it